ok ok ok ok c'est un sujet que je
prépare depuis très longtemps
tiens y'a tout de suite ce que vous
allez voir dans la vidéo les extraits
que vous montrez peuvent choquer j'étais
en studio avec dorcel au mois de juillet
dernier et ont été les heures goûter les
autres sans masque je vous ai vu venir
vous vous dites ça va choquer on parlait
de recel association d'idées un peu
bizarre non c'est juste la distance
physique je veux vraiment précisé en
début de vidéo parce que c'est
extrêmement important tout ce que vous
allez voir toutes été tournées en studio
avec dorcel ça a été tourné au mode
juillet l'été dernier juillet 2020 à
cette époque là le coc vite circulé très
peu et on pouvait effectivement se
permettre de travailler comme ça à
proximité sans masque donc ça c'est une
précision importante je veux la donner
dès le début de la vidéo alors
aujourd'hui le prennent au sujet qui
très particulier un sujet qui est un peu
à part jugé qu est très passionnant
c'est voir comment l'industrie comme
l'industrie du porno réussi à utiliser
les nouvelles technologies pour aller
sur nouveau format le nouveau format
c'est le podcast le podcast interactif
vous allez donc pouvoir converser par
les répondent oui vous directement avec
une intelligence conversationnel de
dorcel c'est une expérience inédite une
expérience que je trouvais en tout cas
assez intéressant surtout content de
pouvoir vous en parler parce que j'étais
là au début j'étais là au tournage sur
la voix off parce qu'ici il y à deux
voix une expérience avec une voix
famille l'expérience avec une voix off
et je puis vous assurer que partiront
studio avec dorcel
c'est une super aventure
[Musique]
j'ai deux bonnes nouvelles la première
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on va aller plus
loin plus en profondeur dans le podcast
fréquence greuze je vous mets le lien en
bas dans la description pour la deuxième
bonne nouvelle c'est que dorcel a décidé
de vous faire un très joli cadeau je ne
vous dit pas quel cadeau que je ne
révèle rien je vous mets juste un lien
également en bas d'un description pour
venir participer à un concours pour
gagner un joli cadeau signé dorcel
à l'occasion de la sortie de leur
podcast interactif et si vous n'êtes pas
encore abonné je vous invite à venir le
faire après que son petit bouton rouge
que vous avez juste ici si les rouges
si vous n'êtes pas abonné cliquez sur le
bouton rouge actionner la cloche comme
ça vous serez notifié qu'une prochaine
vidéo arrivera et ça c'est vachement
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on aurait pu imaginer il ya
quelques années l'industrie du porno
arriver avec quelque chose d'interactif
comme ça moi ce que je trouve vraiment
intéressant avec le système de podcasts
c'est qu'on laisse le champ libre à son
imagination personne ne sait ce que vous
écoutez alors ici comme vous allez
interagir avec bonne voie si vous le
faites dans un lieu public
ça peut paraître un peu bizarre ça pour
okah surprendre quelques personnes
quoique allez savoir
mais ce format je trouve intéressant je
trouve surtout très intéressant car
interactif c'est vous qui choisissez en
rose qui va se passer au travers des
réponses que vous allez fournir
directement donc d'un mois ses liens
nana qui cherchent de nouvelles
aventures c'est pour ça que je me suis
inscrite sur une application
j'ai très envie de rencontrer de
nouvelles têtes et de vivre des
expériences en sous sol le concept est
le suivant vous avez une application web
vous vous connectez et vous contacter
une des deux personnes soient liés à qui
la voix féminine soit les eaux qui est
la voix masculine
ça me rassure on était sur la même
longueur d'onde si on s'était vu la
dernière fois serait plus que bien des
ratés et ça n'aurait pas été que de ma
faute vous allez échanger directement
elle va vous poser des questions vous
allez répondre vous allez guide et
l'expérience pour vous emmener jusqu'à
un point de non retour
mais ça je vous laisserai pas vous même
essayé l'expérience le lien est en bas
dans la description et une expérience
qui est en plus gratuite
attention et c'est une expérience qui
est réservé aux adultes si vous avez
moins de 18 ans ne cliquez pas sur les
liens en bas vous verrez cette vidéo
parce que cette vidéo explique le
fonctionnement le contenu n'est pas du
tout interdit aux mineurs ici par contre
le lien de la description si vous avez
moins 18 ans passez votre chemin
ah merde j'ai bien compris on n'est pas
du tout sur la même longueur d'onde
je te laisse salut
beh des fois faut vraiment envie d'y
aller là où j'ai vu là où c'était ce que
vous voulez là où ce n'était pas un peu
je me demande qui aurait dérapé en
premier tu peux le dire dans ce sens que
tu veut s'y amarrer le meilleur
emplacement ta tête quitter on sent d'un
coup tu peux tu rentre vraiment dans le
personnage ce que ça doit être écrit la
bonne manière
toi je te vois par la fenêtre si tu veux
me dire ça j'en ai dit fais moins de
choses demain aux propositions et moi je
peux te faire des trucs tu vois le genre
jusqu'à ce qu'on puisse arriver system i
comment tu vois toi peut-être interpose
deux autres prendre le temps de dire ok
il se passe ça va se passer ça après
pour installer sa statue
jeudi j'étais juste avec eux y va se
passer ça j'ai déjà fait trois
intonations un peu différente
c'est pas forcément l'intonation de sa
voix qui change c'est plus le rythme que
tu donnes et l'énergie que tu donnes
dans la phrase qui change
comment est ce qu'une entreprise comme
dorcel réussi à se positionner en
utilisant les nouvelles technologies
pour apporter de nouveaux services sur
kate partenaires ils se sont appuyés
comment est ce que tout ça fonctionne
d'un point de vue technique quelle est
la technologie derrière et vous allez
voir que tout est vraiment mais vraiment
extrêmement intéressant
on est avec hugues de dorcel sa vague
très bientôt
ouais super écoute je suis très heureux
je suis en studio aujourd'hui avec vous
à paris déjà avant de parler de dire ce
qu'on fait en studio ce que tu peux toi
te présenter ça va me tuer au sein de
dorcel ok bah je suis maintenant je suis
directeur de passion digital chez dorcel
mais gm à charge tout ce qui va être le
pilotage la roadmap des projets digitaux
dorcel on a une bonne dizaine de sites
web on a va avoir une dizaine
d'applications sur ip tv donc
souhaitable que vous avez sur vos box en
général chez différents opérateurs et on
avoir on a beaucoup travaillé sur des
sujets dits magie dont l'aveyron les
plus de 50 ans
voilà et donc continuer à chercher de
nouvelles idées de nouveaux projets là
vous êtes sur un tout nouveau projet tu
peux décrire un peu l'essence du projet
l'idée moi je le vois je l'avais vue on
est en fin de journée là ça fait depuis
ce matin que vous tournez une voix homme
que tu peux expliquer pour qu'on
comprenne un peu ce qui se passe en fait
alors le projet en fait c'est l' agence
donc vos codes qui nous l'a amené ce
arrivé avec une voix mais dense à me
connecter et là ils ont fait un bond à
écouter et on écoute effectivement la
voix d'une femme qui commence à nous
raconter une histoire mais qui surtout
répond aux interactions de à deux balles
qui nous présentait le produit et on
s'est dit assez marrant parce que sur
l'audio c'est un sujet sur lequel on n'a
pas beaucoup travaillé
donc pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
potes 14 n ya pas de plateforme pascal
holtzer cei a passé genre d'éléments
c'est un milieu où on ne sait pas trop
comment on va là pour l'appréhender et
donc là l'idée c'était parti de cette
opportunité on a voulu travailler sur du
l'audio interactif et pas du podcast
c'est pas
si c'est pas au coq et a coupé les
marques j'imagine mais je me dis voilà
et en fait c'est l'idée c'est de
travailler sur cette thématique là pour
emmener l'utilisateur un fantasque qui
n'est pas habituel puisque on va être
sur l'interface vocale qui est pas du
tout est lié à ce qu'on a sur la
pornographie standard ou sur le monde de
l'érotisme ou la lecture qu'aux le
murmure en moi tu me murmure prends moi
où tu me murmure espaces enfin les
orchestres est-ce que je peux commencer
à lasser de présenter comme ça moi les
choses sont simples on sait qui tu es
directement
ok alors justin c'est vachement
dynamique bonjour donc je m'appelle
antoine g j'ai créé une agence qui est
spécialisée dans l'audio digital donc on
est une jeune agence on a un an et demi
d'existence comme les appels d'urgence
il s'appelle vos codes grâce à google et
amazon on va pouvoir créer des
expériences conversationnel dédié à une
marque ou ou à une expérience qu'on a un
auquel on aura pensé on va créer des
échanges entre l'utilisateur et
l'expérience à dire qu'en fait tu vas te
baser sur un amazon alexa ou sur google
assistant pour pouvoir l'utiliser toi
comme des gardons tous souhaitent en
fait exactement google comme amazon met
à disposition des développeurs tiers la
possibilité d'aller customiser des
applications au sein de l'assistant ok
c'est ce qu'on utilise et derrière en
fait on écrit les scénarios dans ses
applications là qui vont personnaliser
au maximum l'expérience en fonction ce
que va dire l'utilisateur après tout
l'art derrière de la création
d'expériences et de la création de
contenu c'est d'essayer de faire en
sorte que les interactions soient les
plus fluide possible parce qu'on se rend
bien compte que on va pouvoir répondre à
toutes les interrogations toutes les
questions d'utilisateurs donc il faut
penser en amont à comment est-ce qu'on
va diriger l'utilisateur vers tel ou tel
scénario
tu dois anticiper en fait la façon dont
vivent à très grands pas tu dois le
guider pour que tu l'emmènes vraiment
répondre pour des choix que toi tu as
prédéfinis exactement
donc si je comprends bien tu te mets sur
une web app tu entends scénario c'est ça
tu vas pouvoir
et réagir avec la personne voilà sur ce
que tu vois tu vas entendre et ça va
faire évoluer l'histoire donc fait
partie prenante de l'histoire
exactement l'interface principale fera
forcément le mobile pour les gens sont
beaucoup plus d'équipés en mobile
on n'a pas vocation à faire
d'applications puisqu'on n'est pas
autorisé par les store apple et google
donc voilà on est sur un élément plutôt
agnostiques ou on va essayer d'être sur
le navigateur la personne va aller sur
une url qu'on va donner et de cette url
balancer en fait cette application un
site web applications web qui permettra
de vivre cette expérience et de
découvrir en fait ce qu'on a voulu créer
à travers les danses qu'on a
enregistrées par exemple aujourd'hui sur
smartphone mais sur du coup pc mac os 6
mouais bah après il faut avoir un micro
parce que sinon c'est à dire que
l'expérience ça serait dommage de pas
pouvoir répondre
on va apprendre à faire en sorte d'avoir
une interface visuelle aussi ça ça
permet de pallier des fois où soit les
ans de la personne soit ou juste le fait
j'ai loupé une question comment je fais
quoi là si on essaie de travailler sur
des choses un peu plus interactif et
visible pour l'utilisateur
ou est-ce qu'on peut encore aller avec
cette technologie sur la pousse beaucoup
plus loin sur la réfléchit encore plus
on peut aller à peu près partout sur
tous types d'interfaces là aujourd'hui
ce sera on sera sur une interface web
mais on peut imaginer ça sur une
application mobile on peut imaginer un
flashcode qui nous emmène sur
l'expérience conversationnel en fait ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir le
potentiel qu'on peut amener dans une
expérience audio en termes de
personnalisation en fait à partir de
vraiment on peut capter les inputs de
l'utilisateur on va pouvoir adapter
l'expérience en fonction de ce qu'il
veut donc on s'imagine que lorsqu'on va
plus loin qu'un simple oui non et qu'on
peut reconnaître plus de par exemple la
façon dont il parlait ce qui l'énervé
est-ce qu'il est content en fonction ce
qui est vrai qu on va pouvoir avoir une
expérience hyper personnalisé et pour
les marques c'est une promesse de valeur
qu'ils performent derrière elles
viennent te dire on accélère dans
l'histoire allez on les retrouve on
répond quelle est la volonté dorcel
d'aller chercher des nouvelles
technologies comme sa dalle est d'aller
sur l'innovation parce que là clairement
vous allez sur des enfants on va pas
forcément dire vous cherchez pourquoi
moi j'ai l'image de dorcel tu dit dorcel
ces magistrats c'est de l'image c'est du
film tu te dis pas je vais aller
fantasmer sur l'audio après sahin sont
là je l'écouté ça clairement un sens
mais comme ça brûle pourpoint
on vous entend pas là dessus
ya plusieurs choses déjà en effet de
tester progressivement des technologies
qu'on connaît pas l'audio ci à la fois
de la techno mais c'est aussi de
l'expérience qu'on n'est pas habitué à
aller chercher et c'est des choses qui
sont très tendance pour connaître enfin
si on regarde sur le sur le marché de
l'audio l'audio boucle les podcasts
toutes les thématiques audio on vraiment
une fait une percée dans les années
dorées
c'étaient les périodes récentes on va
dire et c'est quelque chose sur lequel
on a une grosse curiosité donc avoir
l'opportunité en plus d'espèces de
curiosité montante là on se dit bon il
faut essayer
on n'est pas en train de monter une
industrie du podcast ou du podcast
interactif on n'est pas en train
d'essayer d'inonder le marché à travers
un produit on est plutôt en train
d'essayer bas on teste quelque chose on
voit comment le marché va réagir
on voit comment les gens pour gagner on
voit déjà comment nous on aime on
appréhende la chose parce que c'est pas
simple mais on n'est pas fou c'est vrai
c'est vraiment très expérimentale et bah
c'est la même chose sur beaucoup de
d'éléments de l'histoire de dorcel ou
basse et en testant des choses qu'ils
ont découvert soit des ddt beau concept
ou alors au contraire des éléments qu'on
est bon bah voilà ça on va pas aller
dans ce sens là parce qu'on peut pousser
c'est trop cher c'est trop compliqué n'y
a pas de marché ça a été des choses
alors qu'il y ait une balle de tester
donc là c'est une bonne opportunité et
puis on découvre un mathématiques qu'on
a qu'on n'aborde pas vous que c'est
prometteur
c'était marrant de voir en studio
comment est-ce qu'ils allaient créer ça
vous voyez effectivement qu'on a un
arbre décisionnel et il faut enregistrer
partie pas partir par exemple l'âge qui
dit on prend notre temps dans l'histoire
l'animal va voir ça et ensuite elle va
voir ça et après le voir descendre là du
coup que tu lis at elle a compilé 36
hockey ça sera pas tout le temps le cas
mais globalement c'est l'idée je pense
que c'est mieux si tu fais ça
alors ya effectivement tout un boulot
d'acteur derrière pour emmener
l'histoire pour la raconter avoir les
bonnes intonations réussir à placer sa
voix correctement il y avait des moments
un petit peu what the fuck parce
qu'effectivement le l'acteur qui
tournait la voix de léo qui fait la voix
de l'est au des biens un moment il
fallait qu'il est un peu côté un peu un
peu essoufflée et pour réussir à être
essoufflée bas il faisait des pompes
funèbres au physique comme était comme
un gosse
[Musique]
2 et goût là tu fais du r porno là y'a
personne que toi tu seras gaffe au
hockey encore tim duncan manche kung fu
team donne tellement chaud c'est
extrêmement intéressant de voir comment
d'orsay l'a fait pour utiliser cette
nouvelle technologie au service de son
business
ici on parle de ça parce que c'est
dorcel on peut imaginer ce service
s'adapter à plein de typologie
d'entreprise a plein de storytelling
différents en créant de l'interaction de
la reconnaissance vocale honneur
décisionnel un peu d'intelligence
derrière une bonne histoire à raconter
et vous avez une solution qui fonctionne
si vous voulez vivre l'expérience je
vous ai mis le lien en bas dans la
description et votent plus pour
participer au concours c'est également
en bas dans la description et pour
écouter le podcast le podcast de nos
succès cette fois ci où on va aller plus
loin dans les explications
le lien est une fois de plus en bas dans
la description comment vous trouvez ce
système de dorcel est ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant est ce que vous
voulez l'essayer
moi ce que vous en pensez on va en
commentaire mineurs s'abstenir sur ce
zoo voir beaucoup d'amour des gros coeur
on continue à parler de technologie et à
très vite
ciao